he's our good friend of the program from
CBS and his inside access program and
Baltimore Maryland every single day and
I don't know the hours but we'll get it
from him right away to make sure that we
get the promo out there cuz he had Sean
Payton on yesterday Jason lock and four
here on the Rich Eisen show how are you
Jason what's going on brother I'm
hanging in there were Birds blesses can
be you know and it's this crazy
environment that we're in so hope hope
you guys are doing well out there as
well what's going on with this James
Harrison story Jason and you had
champagne right in the middle of it and
that that that's what put the bounty
gate I guess lens for this to be looked
through that's what that's where that
came from
that as you saw Harrison is this you
know very upset about on his Instagram
feed today yeah where's this scone what
what what happened here Jason I I don't
know you know we haven't heard from Mike
Tomlin directly about it obviously
Steelers ownership to say nothing to see
here Harrison's agent saying nothing to
see here
but the story that James told on that
podcast and it just was like I didn't
know that that was going to happen the
day we had Sean you know any man I've
been talking to Sean about Connor my
chauffeur for sure that had been plans
that's the way he's wrapped it just so
happened that that came out within an
hour or so of us having him or an arrow
or a couple of hours so I just figured
we might as well see what he thinks of
it you know since he obviously fought
the the league in a way that that few
have and he disputed a lot of the claims
against him and basically Sean's take
was hey it's the Steelers they won't
they won't don't hold your breath
they're not gonna they're not gonna look
into any allegations or anything like
that that's not how the league office
rolls and and then Sean made it clear
that he still upset at the way the
investigation in the Saints was was
handled and that's something that he'll
take to the grave he clearly feels that
there were some ulterior motives there
and obviously a lot of the things that
were leaked about the Saints in that
story when you got around to the nuts
and bolts of what Paul Tagliabue wrote
up it didn't really match up with a lot
of stuff that was out there in the media
originally so
yeah you know rich as to what actually
happened IIIi don't know I mean it did
the the allegation was fairly clear
right I mean I don't think that that
Harrison was alluding to there being
monopoly money in the envelope but I
don't think he was alluding to there
being you know or so peanut butter and
jelly sandwich merit I mean I think we
know was alleging or sort of picture he
was painting it's it's it's so bizarre
the whole thing soup-to-nuts just do you
think the NFL is going to look into this
I would imagine that don't put a
statement out at some point saying hey
we'll follow up I don't I don't think
it's gonna go anywhere you know I mean
sort of net net I don't I don't think
there'll be anything approaching a
deflategate or a bounty gate type scope
to this inquiry you know maybe somebody
from the league office would call James
Harrison maybe somebody from NFL
security but I don't think it's going to
I don't think it's gonna have tremendous
legs rich I just think it's one of these
things where the moment that it happened
in the situation we're in and there is
no sports and I see I think things kind
of blow up now in a way that if we were
in a normal offseason climate and there
was baseball going on in the NBA
playoffs and all that stuff I don't
think it would be quite the Malstrom
then it became well I mean and talk
about burying potentially a lead
normally it would be a lead if a head
coach in the NFL basically says the
officiating home office wasn't equipped
to handle pass interference and monitor
it and and and perform it to the point
where it wasn't one and done which it's
going to be Sean Payton said that on
your show yesterday too and that that's
kind of gotten lost right I mean
absolutely tanked the final game of the
14 season and went out of their way to
lose to the Saints so they could get
Jameis Winston yeah no it was it was
quite I mean Shaw was definitely in a
good mood we had the ball rolling I
think you know the the the P I review he
saying the the quiet part out loud and I
think because of his battles with the
league office and he's always been one
of the more outspoken you know coaches
in the league he has you know he's not
afraid of telling the truth or the truth
is he sees it and I think what he said
no one could dispute it was a mess the
way it was handled from theory to
practice it it it didn't work it didn't
work in any way shape or form I don't
know anybody who thought it looked good
nobody knew what the threshold of clear
and obvious was nobody knew I mean what
level of crime do you have to commit in
order for the league office to overturn
the call and then one other thing one
other thing I want to hit you before I
let you go cuz I know you've got your
show coming up again 2:00 to 6:00 p.m.
Eastern every single weekday you and Ken
Wineman on 105.7 the fan radio in
Baltimore Maryland with inside access
where you had Sean on yesterday and I
guess dj khaled today huh from being a
complete pimp
no it's okay but it's my pleasure let me
pimp it for you words I never thought I
would say without a hint of irony what's
the deal with cam wide why doesn't he
have a gig right now Jason my mind I
think the Ravens here where I do my show
should bring them in are you gonna tell
me he's not better than rg3 can you get
him for five million seven million ten
million I don't know what the price
point will be obviously the injuries are
significant in this and the inability to
get the kind of physical to kind of work
out you'd like to have in a normal
climate has something to do with it and
if I'm cam and I'm seeing what's out
there now I I mean any money he would
get wouldn't be upfront you'd have to
earn it in the future in all likelihood
any way through weekly paychecks it's
not going to be a huge bonus you might
as well continue to get healthy do your
thing and see what's on the other side
of this and and unfortunately there will
be injuries if there is football we know
that much so I don't think cam is is
really pressed right now but sent I
don't get that sense from from anybody
in his camp this hasn't been a good
quarterback economic climate for pretty
much anybody except for you know Ryan
Tannehill and and a couple of other
exceptions
so you might as well wait it out thanks
for the call Jason nice scoop yesterday
brother anytime dude let me get you back
on that week you got some time you're
not a reach you now to reach me you got
how will you like a stocking for of CBS
right there hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here